to st. Louis
sweetness is still working on the
aircraft estimated time of departure 40
I don't believe that
Cincinnati beat st. Louis this time
we're still fine
we're still fine that was an optimistic
that was actually pretty good we'll see
my cups I'm Mike I'm a little bit hungry
yeah even after the shake oh but I can
fight I need a coffee
yeah yeah that will get me through
LaBella role of man for that [ __ ] yeah
yeah no control no just paint all in it
but like a tsunami there ain't no
calming this one day dog we don't change
all the [ __ ] we know difference that
song see you don't go tripping
please don't hold your head low Pippi
when you get in hiding the Four Seasons
right yes my snapchat literally froze on
update for the last several hours late
to San Francisco we're in st. Louis that
in San Francisco what's all [ __ ] up
maybe weather
you're the best you get him dude you
know what's better in five hours
do Buddy catch which one
I gotta work now heading to Barnes &
Noble everything stores its ending
minutes thank you so much soul
it's Ang's birthday you know Hank I
thank you Khanna became in on March 8th
- no yeah that's interesting do you
think
Wesley
really cool dude that's like a celebrity
factor in that [ __ ] for now yeah people
like what the [ __ ] yeah like I even
[ __ ] said I'm like do you know you
know you're following a hugger in and
that's what it is right now headed to
the event
Andy is here tell them and tell them
we're gonna [ __ ] rip your faces on
faces off faces we had one at the st.
Louis Airport where our delayed and we
missed it how quick listen does it take
I don't even know what this light is
this is a new filter
yeah that's call the [ __ ] cops are
about to get us down here oh that's even
better
is that a new filter for real oh I don't
[ __ ] I think we use Brian did he get you
did you update your uh it's part of like
can you update your snapchat yeah you
have an update lot the fonts different
it yeah just a couple hours ago anyway
usually wrote after we met a couple of
months ago I ordered all your books I've
been reading them simultaneously with
time permits the new askgaryvee book was
delivered today and though I'm only 17
pages in I can tell you that this is
going to be huge it blows away the other
great
that's awesome yeah that's a long team
you know what this has a shot view this
really is it's literally it's literally
the three books combined 2016 yeah dude
it's nothing like that's literally
literally when I wrote I basically wrote
the three books sort of the things on my
mind over like a period of time and then
this is just like if you think about it
I like there's plenty of motive like you
and I probably have the best read on at
the rock cuz we sat there for [ __ ] 11
hours in the audiobook like I remember
thinking like oh here's crush it [ __ ]
that's good because that stuff really
[ __ ] works right oh here like Guy
Kawasaki whew do you know guy is your
big guy Tech his like he [ __ ] what
say yeah he [ __ ] putting something on
Facebook library that was like look at
the end he's like this and he never says
curses he's like a proper guys like look
bottom line this isn't one of those
[ __ ] business books that's like be
authentic and do it of course beyond
that they can do it he's like there is a
ton of practical advice
how are you I see you such a pleasure
man thank you brother how are you going
you for a while
very good look nice to meet you man
thank you
John I thought this is part of Chris
business partner
Oh
thank you
to guarantee now a nice to meet you
buddy Steve Albert steam drill play nice
to meet you
real pleasure gonna say it
he's a good buddy of mine Greg grace the
kitchen plunger really nice table for
you
please Gary
thank you brother I love you too man
what's your name Austin Evans awesome
thank you my pleasure thank you coming
tonight Andy
- the funny thing is - we gave everybody
drinks beforehand beautiful setup man
beautiful tapas love it ah this was my
favorite this by the way I gotta take a
picture with this this was my favorite
Beckett of all time it made so much
money this day this is my favorite
Beckett of all time this was the 90
score bo Jackson
I ripped off everybody in seventh and
eighth grade loaded up and I made Bank
rock and now you're asking me how I'm
feeling because you're trying to makes
it daily that's 21 content you know wait
a minute you put up some staff without
you gotta always pay attention to the
filters we got the filter up here you
see you next Andy I want to get pictures
you got it how are ya how are we sit you
on the right dar we look I'm trying to
do the filter thing hello let me see the
filter holy [ __ ] Mike look at my filter
I'm literally wearing the outfit so I
don't even know it's [ __ ] crazy you
got a book that is so unbelievable Liz
thank you so so much Liz thank you so
much for buying it at Barnes & Noble
we're gonna put you in daily be 21 for
doing it yeah thank you
I'm a boxer he's a professional really
yeah I am
what's your name Sal Sol dude that's
amazing
can I get a little can I get a little
flavor can I hear it
amazing such a talent good for you
all right great I'll take you for a
little bit thank you brother so my man
there's so much [ __ ] content being
made right now they're just [ __ ]
content on content on content now I'm
ready I'm super ready let's go do a
north-south there's so much content the
most content
my boy
we could have been anywhere tonight put
them in your left thank you so much for
having me I'm super excited we're here
so what I do for a living is I realize
that 95 percent of money and energy is
wasted it's wasted in tactics and it's
wasted in creating a fake North Star
recalling the beginning of my talk it's
wasted in creating a fake North Star of
what success is or not having the
emotional strength to decide what
winning is for yourself and letting
somebody else define what winning is
your girl your parents somebody you look
up to please please please understand
there are very basic things that need to
get done to win one play your game
always be on the offense for what
matters to you and to realize that if
you do not have a skill if you do not
have skills you don't deserve to build a
business you can't just read about it
you can't just listen to podcasts about
it
you can't just be about it you got to
have [ __ ] skills have skills know
what you want to happen for yourself
nobody else there's that know how many
people so rocky for like that the
Russian one just raised me as I want to
know remember that part where Drago
before the fight he plays like Yahtzee
bi eats like I'm doing this for myself
like [ __ ] you Russia that [ __ ] be
[ __ ] Drago do your [ __ ] for you not
what everybody else wants you to do that
my friends is how you win and like I
spent most of my 20s
sitting with 80 and 90 year old people
constantly I was very [ __ ] weird I
would go in public I would roll up on 80
[ __ ] year old I mean people that look
like they might die before the
conversation was over
airplanes I would switch seats sit with
an old [ __ ]
and I would [ __ ] drill those people
and ask the question after question
after question and those old [ __ ]
strangers people that [ __ ] died six
weeks after I've met that those people
formed my life because I looked at 50 to
100 people that lived it and their [ __ ]
was the same let me say this to this
crowd how do you make your money is way
more important than how much you make
how you make your money is way more
important than how much you make when
you're 80 and your grandkids and your
kids are talking about your life doing
what you wanted to instead of what
everybody else wants you to do is the
number one thing it's the number one
thing and so many of us didn't have the
strength that 15 16 17 to not do what
society or our parents want us to do the
cool thing is it's never too late
it just isn't like I made a video about
60 year old entrepreneurs that went
quite viral for me and like the emails
are flooding in and it's [ __ ] crazy
like it's just never too late so guys
it's basic but it's hard and it takes
work and so I wish you nothing but
success and I would and I really hope
you understand the practicality that my
talk was framed in because way too many
people are wishing who they are instead
of realizing who they are too many
people in this room are hoping for
something without understanding that
there's so much better to be grounded in
what it is and then going all-in on that
I'm completely convinced and I watch it
every day that you can overshoot your
ambition by by understanding who you are
and then just being patient that in a
15-year window you are far more
successful than if you run to the thing
that you're not in a six-year window
there's way too many stories of this you
know them don't be one of those
statistics it's hard and the only way to
win is to put yourself in the best
position to succeed
and finally and then let's go into QA
complaining is some [ __ ] [ __ ] I need to
get more serious about this topic I
literally never complain during decades
but other than that I literally never
complained complaining is literally the
biggest waste of good energy you could
ever imagine
with all due respect and this is the
truth nobody gives a [ __ ] it's just true
and it's honestly the closest like just
so you know and I've spent a lot of time
with winners at this point complaining
is the most obvious tell of a non
winning player just stop [ __ ]
complaining thank you
thank you going through
we found something in April in La find
out all right I'm convinced we know and
if not we'll do it for five hustling
because you could do both yeah you could
yeah you just aren't going to be able to
[ __ ] go to the Cardinals game you
know and I mean like so you know what I
mean yeah awesome thank you nice I wish
you well no I think this book is so good
that it's in my best long-term interest
to get it into as many people's hands as
possible
legacy oh great right it's real tell
myself what's up I'll make it forward to
say well god yes and you pray bring it
it was really nice meeting you man yeah
thanks man
okay what no no no it's a matter of fact
I know that meditations about to explode
and I'm not gonna do that either
I feel so happy with my [ __ ] that I
would never [ __ ] with it you know I'm
just a pure bred kind of thing you know
like I got what I got it's good [ __ ]
just got a good genetics yeah I don't
I've never smoked or I've never like I
don't like to [ __ ] with me myself
especially the thing that would scare me
the most is something with my brain cuz
I'm so happy with it you know hey what's
real pleasure good luck to you brother
do your thing yeah thank you man yeah
let's do it
like I work 18 hours and you know I
sleep the other six like I think too
many people like you'll lose you you
don't sleep you die like there's it's
not super complicated I'm not trying I'm
trying to win the hot what I'm doing
while I'm awake but I'm not trying to
prove that I don't sleep like swoop is
[ __ ] I slept like 11 hours the other
day like because I was just like
catching up like [ __ ] yeah man sleep
is [ __ ] the jam that's why I was
going like [ __ ] I never do it like
I'd [ __ ] almost I miss planes like I
never want to let anybody down come back
out yep I mean listen if somebody waits
another [ __ ] hour nope yeah let's do
it
so what we're just gonna kind of go
through it yeah
like you guys want to kind of like I
mean I think we should just go around
and just do specific questions and kind
of jam on it right my man it's you got
it you got the right analogy nobody did
videoblogging and then like like nobody
did ecommerce like all the good [ __ ]
comes from nobody doing got it yeah we
are the night and you're doing a good
job with this you're pounding at home on
all night you don't need permission from
who what you guys are not only what you
guys are by the way you guys are barking
up a secondary reason I'm on the attack
on all this [ __ ] the reason you guys
are looking for permission is because
you know so many people are fakers
that's why you're stuck I am Telling You
I did it to the highest levels I don't
want to be a pundit and I want to be an
operator I don't want to be in the
business of being Gary Vee I want to
build businesses and so that's when you
guys are struggling with in a different
version but the truth is it doesn't
matter like I took me a lot like the
truth is I've come to realize I motivate
people because I was gifted that DNA and
like I shouldn't take that away from
them because it helps them to love it
thank you
yeah I make it out to by the way that's
the that you know what this is the you
know what this is the number one thing
that most people never know about this
[ __ ] they see these like level up [ __ ]
like hey by 500 books and get the visit
of that they don't realize that like
it's just it's just energy exchange like
what were we supposed to be here for
yeah like like you know what I mean like
people don't get it yeah yeah yeah oh my
making out - yeah man good job
yeah impressment vibe thanks man yes my
making
you know that's because that's what I
always always say to people when I can't
just sign them like a baby but like yeah
my pleasure brother do get a kick out
think you over I gotta have do you want
to make that to this see see what cya
later tonight get back to the AFC
Championship game until 98 you know 16
years later to Denver which was a
heartbreaker I do all and still in it at
that living what they got no you can't
be scared to go kitty stay with that
vision don't know hot 236 in the morning
4:30 wake-up call mission
my 43 from creep City to the beam since
I moved to the city I never sleep said
if I busted through this gotta do it
right I'm on the block with my youngest
child shed some light
my brother teasing in the pan for the
second time I ain't trying to see his
cell again in us all my life